today on the matt walsh show a
conservative actress is fired by disney
after outrage over her anti-semitic
quote-unquote and supposedly offensive
post but her posts were neither
anti-semitic nor offensive we'll talk
about the real reason she got the axe
also five headlines including the cdc's
new endorsement of double masking and
the byte administration announces plans
to get schools back open
half of the schools one day a week is
that enough and in our daily
cancellation we will discuss the crucial
differences between
breastfeeding and chest feeding all of
that and much more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're about to talk about a company
that does not share
our values as conservatives um and there
are a lot of those companies out there
probably companies that you support
whether you know it or not and that's
why it's so important at least
to balance things out by supporting the
companies that support us and our values
and uh and i'll give you one top of the
list charity mobile one company that
fits
the description of one that supports our
values is charity mobile the pro-life
phone company five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro-family
charity of your choice new activations
and eligible accounts get a free cell
phone with free activation and free
shipping plus there's no contracts
there's no termination fees
there's no risk with a 30-day guarantee
what all that means is that
you might as well you know you might as
well give it a try might as well try it
out there's there's no risk for you
got nothing to lose and uh at the same
time you're also going to get live
customer service based right here in the
usa
a lot of other perks as well that you
get with charity mobile you have the
ability to block the use of cellular
data picture messages text messages on
any or all of your lines
especially as a parent that's something
that's going to be really important and
if you're looking to monitor your usage
and pay your bill and all that you want
convenience well they got a free app
for you to do that and all the while
you are helping to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company
you can turn every day living into
effortless giving for the charity of
your choice
i am a charity mobile user i can't
recommend it enough it's a great service
great all around everything about it's
just a it's a win-win for everybody
involved
and if you want to check out charity
mobile then what i would say is call
with them 1-877-474-3662 at
charitymobile.com you probably know i'm
not a fan of disney or star wars
and had never seen the mandalorian or
heard the name gina carano
before yesterday what i learned about
miss carano though from reading
mainstream media
headlines and sifting through some of
the tweets under the
fire gina carano hashtag is that she's a
bigot
and a psychopath and a transphobe and an
anti-semite and a danger to herself and
others
i learned that she has now been booted
from her role on the mandalorian and
fired by disney
a cause for celebration i'm told after
an instagram post that became sort of
the final straw
that post has been reported by media
outlets like usa today and chicago sun
times
as straightforwardly anti-semitic not
even like
some people claim it's anti-semitic or
some people see it as anti-semitic but
that it is just simply anti-semitic
this gina chrono person i mean she seems
like a pretty unsafe character
anti-semitic posts transphobic
she's bigoted all these things pretty
pretty bad
or she would seem that way to anyone
stupid enough
to still take the popular narrative at
face value the rest of us
will want to do a little bit more
research into the topic and form our own
judgments
it doesn't it doesn't take much research
to discover that the narrative
is once again completely and utterly
bogus
so what did the now deleted instagram
post that has been dubbed anti-semitic
by not only the media but her former
employer actually say
i mean lucasfilm sent out a statement
declaring that carano's
quote social media posts denigrating
people based on their cultural and
religious
religious beliefs are abhorrent and
unacceptable
abhorrent and unacceptable is there any
basis
for this charge well decide for yourself
the post in question appears to be
a screenshot of somebody else's post
which carano had
reposted to her own instagram it says
this is what it says
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children because history is
edited most people today don't realize
that to get to the point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews
the government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
jews
how is that any different from hating
someone for their political views
that's it that was the post anti-semitic
denigrating people based on their
cultural and religious identities what
it's it's the it's the opposite of that
actually
she is comparing our current political
environment to nazi germany
in an unfavorable way she's not saying
it's good that it's like this
and by the way if making a nazi
comparison is anti-semitic
then everyone in the country is a raging
anti-semite
as everyone knows nazi comparisons are
the most common rhetorical strategy in
any debate
may be way overused and they are and
overwrought and they often are
but there's nothing shocking or
offensive or abhorrent
about this one single example of a thing
that you can find
in a billion other places on the
internet and everyone has done it
jews and non-jews alike we we have all
been uh guilty apparently
at various points of making nazi
analogies
in fact as nazi analogies go this this
one gets closer to the truth than most
i mean she's correct that the lead up to
any holocaust level atrocity always
involves the dehumanization of a certain
group of people
now i would say this has already
happened in this country to the unborn
60 million have been slaughtered because
of it
is it happening to conservatives too
well we're not being rounded up and
executed
obviously but her point is simply to
show where trends can lead
when taken to their most violent extreme
now say what you want about that but if
you say that she's
denigrating jews somehow then well
you're lying
straight up and i hope she has a team of
lawyers ready to sue lucasfilm for this
defamation that is defamation of
character
they accused her of doing something that
she absolutely did not do it's not even
that you can
you could interpret it in that way you
cannot
and no literate person could read what
she posted and see that as her
denigrating jews
we could of course sit here all day
pulling examples of leftists making nazi
and holocaust comparisons they spent
four years doing it relentlessly every
day
and donald trump never staged any mass
executions of any political dissidents
yet they didn't stop anyone from calling
him hitler we could even pull examples
of
of other disney actors on the same show
making nazi comparisons pedro pascal
um another actor on the mandalorian
tweeted in 2018
uh hashtag this is america
and you can see it here it says he says
this is america hashtag with a picture
of
jews and concentration camps in 1944 um
on top of a picture of the infamous kids
in cages in america in 2018.
so there's the nazi comparison except
that as far as i can tell
that's not really from 2018 it's from
2010 and it's not from america either
well minor details oh and by the way
it's it's also those kids are also not
in a cage you could tell if you look at
the far left
end of the of the photo there that
there's
there's a large opening where the kids
can come and go
so it's a picture of kids in cages in
america in 2018
except it's not from 2018 it's not from
america and they're not in a cage
hey other than that i'd say it's
correctly labeled
in any case despite common
misconceptions trump was not rounding up
and executing immigrants
he detained them as obama did and as bin
biden is doing right now
and then if they were here illegally he
sent them home
that is not at all even slightly
analogous to nazi germany
no part of that is the same
the only similarity is that both
involved governments
and both involved some form of
detainment so by pedro's logic
every government then is effectively a
nazi government including the current
one running this country right now
but he wasn't fired for that the reason
has a lot to do with those pronouns that
you can see
in his bio um which function like the
the lamb's blood on the door
signaling for the angel of cancellation
to pass over
incidentally that's one of the other
offensive things that carano did or or
didn't do
one of the straws before the final one
apparently she refused to put pronouns
in her bio
now that's really one of the things that
made people mad at her is that she
didn't have pronouns in her bible
and then when she finally did um
in in reference to rt r2d2 she she said
that her pronouns were boop
beep boop which just which is pretty
funny
but you're not allowed to joke about the
sacred pronouns we must not joke that
that is heresy
one of several heretical outbursts from
carano whose real sin
whose only sin as far as the left is
concerned is that she doesn't agree
with them she has a number of views that
do not align
with leftism she expressed those views
and that's why they wanted
her destroyed and ultimately they got
what they wanted
what do we learn from this well um
nothing
really i mean we learned what we already
knew that we live in a time when rigid
ideological conformity is demanded
karano
isn't being shipped off to a death camp
of course but her case her case does
demonstrate the sort of dehumanization
that you do find in our culture she's
being lied about
and defamed and the people doing it
know what they're doing and they don't
care
they can look at that post she put up
there they know that's not anti-semitic
and they also know that
they themselves have made exactly that
kind of point a million times
but they're defaming her anyway they
honestly believe that anyone who
disagrees with them
deserves that treatment you can lie
about them and destroy them it doesn't
matter
they do not recognize any kind of moral
obligation or standard when dealing with
the cultural heretics
you can shut them down shut them up cast
them out lie about them that's the only
goal
so ironically the point karana was
making in her supposedly offensive
instagram post
has been aptly illustrated by the
outrage response to it
now let's get to our five headlines
very excited to announce today a new
sponsor on the show
40 days for life and it's a great
organization i've
i've worked with them in the past i've
i've been a fan of 40 days for life for
a very long time
uh and this is just this one of those
perfect fits like a glove 40 days for
life for the matt walsh show
look this if the state of the culture
frustrates you like it frustrates all of
us
uh we now have politicians lobbying for
infanticide
all of these things we have the
democrats in charge and they're
and they're we know their radical
pro-abortion agenda and what's what we
can expect of the next four years
um but here's the thing you know where i
see real progress
is at the grassroots level in 40 days
for life we've talked about this on this
show
we've got things going on at the
national level it's hard to control
those things especially with
uh especially with democrats in charge
but
there's so much we can do on the local
level there's so much that you can do in
your own community at the grassroots
level and that's where 40 days for life
that's where they specialize
that's where they've done all of their
work 40 days for life went from one
peaceful prayer vigil in front of a
planned parenthood in texas to now
1 000 cities in 66 countries 40 days of
prayer fasting and law abiding vigils
have saved 18 000 babies from abortion
they've helped 211 abortion workers
leave their jobs
and they have closed 107 abortion
facilities including
the texas location that now serves as
the headquarters of 40 days for life
how great is that they shut down um an
abortion facility and now it's their
headquarters
be part of the beginning of the end of
abortion by joining one million
volunteers and sign up for your location
at 40daysforlife.com
you can also stay updated on the number
one pro-life podcast 40 days for life
the largest spring campaign ever is
happening from february 17th
through march 28th these guys they know
what they're doing if you're looking for
a pro
pro-life organization to be involved in
then you've got to try
40 days for life don't wait for
washington to heal our culture
go to work in your neighborhood at
40daysforlife.com
i told you guys though i told you guys
about star wars i i've been saying it
for years i told you
star wars sucks we got to move on from
star wars how often have i said this
and i've been i hate to be proven i hate
to say i told you so i'm in fact well
actually that's not true i love saying i
told you so and i'll say it again i told
you so
this star wars thing now we don't need
to debate the
the the original three movies i i think
those also are
just massively overrated the acting is
not very good the script
leaves a lot to be desired the ideas in
the film are not
at all original um it's just sort of
like a space
a a you know a soap opera in space but
um fine so but they were
people have nostalgic attachment to them
and i get that you grew up watching them
and
so you have this attachment i understand
i respect that but
okay now we can can we just move on can
we be done with star wars can we move on
from it can
can society move on have we have we seen
enough of this by now
the last arguably decent star wars movie
was what like
three decades ago and everything since
then has been terrible
um and there's not it's it's
there wasn't that much there to begin
with
with the story it there really was never
40 years worth of story in
this uh thing that george lucas came up
with
because what you hear from people is
that well the the star wars universe
there's so many stories to tell in the
star wars universe
yeah well you know what there's a lot of
stories to tell in the actual universe
i mean there's a whole universe out
there you can come up with any other
kind
you want you want to tell a sci-fi story
tell a sci-fi story it doesn't have to
be star wars
it doesn't have to exist in the star
wars universe make up your own universe
that's what you can do it's fantasy
sci-fi tell your own story
it doesn't have to be tangentially
connected to star wars
that's not really related to the gina
carano thing but
i bring it up anyway okay number one
from abc news
fit matters when it comes to your mask
protecting you against the virus that
cause cover 19
and layering a well-fitted cloth mask
over a surgical mask is likely to prove
beneficial according to new findings
released wednesday
by the centers for disease control
prevention the findings were not
expected to lead to new mask
recommendations by the cdc
uh the public health agency mentioned or
maintains that everyone h2 and older
should weary face covering when outside
their home it also doesn't change the
recommendation that primarily medical
workers in high-risk environments should
rely
on n95 masks um but either way now
they're now they are recommending they
are telling us that we should wear two
masks
or rather they're endorsing the idea of
two masks not officially recommending it
but that that will come i i hope by now
we can all
we all understand how this works so
originally we're told
that you don't need to wear two masks
and then maybe you do and now it's yeah
you probably should but we're not
recommending it and then you know in a
week or two it's gonna be yeah
we're recommended and then we could do
after that it's you're required to
it's not enough to have one you need to
have two
and i i my i will say again
my my primary argument against wearing
two masks
it's not that i don't think it doesn't
work um
it's not it's not any health-based thing
that's not my argument
but i don't even care about that that's
not my point
uh my argument is that it's absurd
that it's absurd it's
it looks stupid it's undignified
and that's my that's my entire argument
i think that's what our argument should
be
yeah i already see some people making
the mistake of well let's
no according to the science it does it's
not it's not any better
um that's not really if you don't want
to wear two masks
is that actually your reason that you
just don't think it's effective
or is it that it's really stupid and it
looks dumb and you don't feel like doing
it
because i think that that is probably
your argument like it's mine and that's
good enough that should be good enough
because when you make the argument based
on how effective it is
then they could just bring in all their
experts and say no you're wrong it's
effective
and since you have structured your
argument that way
well now i guess you gotta wear the two
masks
so better to just be honest about it and
i'll say right now i don't
looking at their numbers they say
whatever it's 80 90 whatever they say
i don't care i'm not doing it because i
don't want to do it
and it looks stupid and that is 100 my
reason and that is good enough
meanwhile the cdc uh also released a
masking
psa well um this is to make the masks
look cool and trendy and
to get all get everyone to wear them so
let's let's play that now
this is a cdc psa on masking here it is
oh it's on
release the meteor
okay so we've got we got all of our
favorite cinematic characters
he's looking at you kid and they've all
got masks
and the cdc saying
[Music]
if you want to get back to doing what we
love to do we got to wear the masks and
slow the spread
there's harry potter there's wonder
woman in the mask
mask up america it says but none of them
were wearing two masks though
so we got i guess we got to update that
psa
with the uh with the two masks
yeah i'm just not doing it it's as
simple as that
now we're not wearing the two masks it's
completely ridiculous it looks stupid
and uh and also it's
i would imagine it's very uncomfortable
and i like to be able to breathe
i don't care if they say well
technically you could still breathe with
two masks and it's not restricting your
airflow that much
yeah it it it feels uncomfortable it
feels like i can't breathe and that's
good enough for me
that's enough reason for me not to wear
it all right number two the biden
administration has plans
to get schools back open uh they've got
they got a plan in place
and under their plan here's what their
plan is to get schools back
open okay in a hundred days they want to
have
half of the schools open in america for
one day a week
in a hundred days and jen
pasaki was asked about this uh at the
white house press conference yesterday
and here's what she had to say
if i could just follow up with you on
comments you made yesterday about school
reopenings
you said the goal was for more than 50
of schools to have some teaching
in person at least one day a week you
said you hoped it would be higher
but why is the administration setting
the bar at
one day a week why not go higher well
certainly we are not uh planning to uh
celebrate
at 100 days if we reach that goal uh
that is
our own effort to make our own set our
own markings
bold and um set an embolden ambitious
agenda for how we're going to measure
ourselves and progress but we certainly
hope to build from that even at 100 days
and from there our objective the
president's objectives is for
all schools to reopen to stay open uh to
be open five days a week for kids to be
learning
that's what our focus is on this is
simply a goal for a hundred days
a lot of schools are already doing that
and for working parents
one day a week doesn't help a whole lot
that's again
the bar of where we'd like the majority
of schools across the country to be
which they're not at this point in time
and we want to build from there and it
really depends it differs from
school district to school district part
of the reason that there is funding
in the american rescue plan is to ensure
that school districts that
don't have the funding they need to
ensure they are equipped to reopen
to meet that bar and exceed it uh are
able to do exactly that
okay so 100 days half schools have the
schools open for for uh for one day a
week and that's
and but she says that's just the
beginning we'll start
there okay so if it takes a hundred days
to get half the school's open for one
day a week
how long until all of the schools open
are open for five days a week
i mean do the math on that we've got
several years to go it would seem
and there's no there's there's no reason
to take there's no reason for this
whatsoever this is pure cowardice on the
part of the
by administration they they know i mean
everybody knows now
that there's no reason for the schools
to have ever been closed to begin with
the schools that are oh there are some
schools that are open right now and
they're not having massive outbreaks
so we've got all the reason the world to
just open the schools up
you don't need to you don't need to
taper it you don't need to
you don't need any complicated plan to
do it gradually
just open up the schools how do you open
them open them open up the doors and say
hey kids come to school
and say to the teachers hey come to your
jobs and if you're not going to do that
we'll fire you
no big loss we'll find somebody else to
do the job you know the thing is there's
a lot of people have lost their jobs
as we know over the last year so
if if there are people who have jobs and
are getting paid and are unwilling to do
what they're getting paid to do
fantastic get rid of them and there's
going to be a whole bunch of people out
there
who would be more than willing to do
that job and can step in
all right number three from ifl science
i'm not going to tell you what ifl
stands for you can look it up
kids well don't look it up kids but uh
iflies.com
says a study looking at the language
people use when they're going through
breakups has found that markers of an
impending breakup can be seen
three months before the breakup occurs
researchers from the university of texas
at austin looked at
over a million posts from six thousand
eight hundred and three reddit users
i wonder how much money they got how
much funding did they get for this study
the users were specifically chosen
because they had posted on the subreddit
breakups hmm
okay well how do you know uh so
these researchers we're trying to find
out you know people posting on these
subreddit breakups
like how can you tell that they're about
to break up
i don't know maybe it's because they're
posting on
a subreddit called breakups it's because
they're posting and saying that they
want to break up
but the article considers no it's all it
says no before you think it the
indication that a breakup was coming was
not them posting in this particular
forum
but the fact that they had posted there
as well as on many other areas of reddit
gave researchers the opportunity to see
how their breakups affected their use of
language oh
okay still stupid but okay the team who
published the results in the proceedings
of the national academy of sciences
looked at posts before
during and after the breakups across two
years of posts
they found that language markers
indicating a breakup began three months
beforehand
okay so what are the this is what
actually matters what how do you know if
you're about to
deal with a breakup um what are the
language markers you can look for and it
says
signs included an increase in i words we
words and cognitive processing words
whatever that means and drops in
analytic thinking
indicating more personal and informal
language
so you say i and we a lot and you don't
you you don't engage in a lot of great
analytic thinking that's
that's a sign that there's a breakup
coming of course that applies to like 95
of the country so uh for instance in the
example below the study the the words in
bold show
signs of cognitive processing as well as
the abundance of eye words so here's an
example of
something someone says which shows
they're about to break up i'm undecided
whether or not to share my story i need
some help because i feel lost but my
story is long and not sure whether it's
worth sharing so that's an example
a lot of cognitive processing a lot of
eye words and that's how you know the
breakup is coming
i think this is all quite silly i'll
tell you
the written clue that your your
relationship is in trouble
you don't need to get into cognitive
processing and i and me words and
everything that's that's not it
here's how you know if you're and i
think most people understand this
but in case you don't if you're getting
text messages
from your significant other that
feature periods the period we all know
is a signal especially if it's a if it's
a one word or even
one sentence text message with a period
then you know you're in trouble you know
the breakup is coming
i think we all we all understand that
now that's uh the period is passive
aggressive
and i don't like this i'm a fan of
punctuation but this is what's happened
now that even me now when i send a text
message to somebody
and it's one word or one sentence i
don't use the period anymore
i used to do that until i was informed
that when
when you do that it is always
interpreted as the other person thinks
you're angry
so that's how you know um so yes if your
girlfriend sent you a text message with
a period it means that she's gonna break
up with you
that's what that's what it means here's
a fun celebrity tweet
the rapper common quotes ayanna presley
and it says
poverty is not naturally occurring it's
a policy choice
poverty is not naturally occurring it is
a policy choice i just wanted to put
that up for there for you because
uh a lot of people retweeting that big
reaction to that a lot of people on the
left
this is this is the kind of rhetoric
they like
and this is the this is the level of
thought that you get
from the left now from the new stars of
the left
in the democrat party poverty is not
naturally occurring it's a policy choice
of course in reality right poverty is
like
the most naturally occurring thing in
the world
at least at least in relation to the
human species
at least societally speaking poverty is
one of the most naturally occurring
things in the world
but before the industrial revolution i
don't know the exact number you can look
it up
but i'm guessing that for the entirety
of human civilization
up until the industrial revolution
probably well over 90 percent of the
human population probably well over 90
was in poverty by our standards and by
their own
um so that's that is really the natural
state for people
is to not have wealth it's unfortunate
it's but it's the reality
this of course is what this is this is
required though on the left you have to
see
poverty is a choice and that means that
you know anyone who's
in poverty now they are they're the
victim of of somebody
most likely they're the victim of a rich
person
if you are rich it means that you are
you the money that you have you are
you are depriving it you're depriving
someone else of that wealth
wealth just by having it of course total
nonsense it's a it's a it's a nice
slogan you could put it on bumper
sticker
but it is disturbing to think that
our lawmakers are actually that stupid
all right number five
i've had this in the queue for quite a
while and uh i want to finally play it
for you
the website lgbtq nation always with the
important news
says quote a video on twitter went viral
showing one
showing one trans lesbian's response to
a transphobic
trope now trans lesbian that would be a
biological male who's attracted to
women a straight guy basically um
twitter user eva uploaded a video that
visually and beautifully took on the
hateful notion that transgender people
are just playing dress-up
so okay so this is a video that's
supposed to destroy
anti-trans talking points from a trans
lesbian
otherwise known again as a male
attracted to females is a bombshell
video
destroys all of the the anti-trans
talking points
and uh here it is right here let's watch
so as a trans woman i've gotten a lot of
strange comments over the years
about my body and appearance and one
that always sticks out to me is
you know wearing a dress doesn't make
you a woman
and like wearing a what i'm sorry
wearing what did you say like a dress
a dress like like this or maybe
uh more like this sorry i just i don't
really wear
okay well this one's kind of cute
or how about this okay
so that's it debunked debunked
if you thought that um men have penises
and women have vaginas
you've you've just been debunked it's
it's over
that's that's science right there now if
you're listening on audio what what was
happening there is the uh the trans
individual
was changing outfits and
sometimes he was wearing a dress other
times he's wearing more uh
you know outfits that are more masculine
and this is supposed to prove
something i don't i don't know what
exactly
no this is maybe something people on the
lgbt left don't understand we
we know i i understand that anyone can
wear any outfit i i totally get that
but the whole point is that putting on a
certain outfit
doesn't actually change your biology
that's the point
we get the same thing anytime there's a
story about uh
and in fact we'll talk more about this
in the daily cancellation but when
there's a story about
a man giving birth we could see it you
know and maybe we'll see a picture of a
guy with
not a guy but an individual with with
facial hair
uh with uh you know wearing male
clothing
but with the pregnant belly and that's
supposed to prove something
to us no yeah we get it that's that's a
woman that's a female
who's gotten some surgery and is you
know taking hormone pills and is wearing
a certain kind of outfit but still a
female
that doesn't blow my mind at all i'm
perfectly aware that anyone can wear any
outfit
in fact that's that's my point
that you can wear whatever outfit you
want just because you're a guy
doesn't mean that you have to wear
outfits that we
culturally associate with men but the
point is if you do put on a different
outfit if you put on
an outfit we can't we associate with
women it doesn't make you a woman
so once again we are the ones saying
that
men you know men are free to wear
whatever the hell they want to wear
but you're still going to be a man while
you do it
all right now let's move to our newest
beloved segment
reading the youtube comments where we
read the youtube comments um
first this is from john reed yesterday
on the show he says
and a lot of comments like this i have
to admit uh but john reed says
matt that cardigan has to go
i did wear a cardigan on the show
yesterday and got very bad reviews and
here's here's the thing i blame my wife
for it
now i make no apologies for the cardigan
i think i look great and i
now i'm going to wear the cardigan more
often just despite all of you
and you're cardigan shaming but i really
blame my wife
because i i was talking to my wife later
that night
and i said you know i wore the cardigan
today people seem and people are making
fun of it they just seem not to like it
and she said to me you wore that yeah
what
and then she explained to me that it
looks terrible why that's see that's
it's your job to make sure that i don't
look terrible when i leave the house
as a woman as the wife that's your job
so if i leave the house looking awful
really this falls on you so blame my
wife for that
and john reed you're banned from
listening to the show heather hyde says
just want to say i love your wife
perhaps you used to think you were your
own man but it's about time you realize
you are her husband
love and light from new orleans that's
that is part of
marriage though isn't it that's
something that probably people don't
understand in modern culture but
uh when you be when you get married you
are not totally your own anymore that's
part of
marriage is part of the the miracle of
that sacrament of marriage when you say
i do you are
you are coming together you're being
bonded as one in a real in a very real
and spiritual sense
um someone who with the
with the username i'm not your buddy guy
says what is the political makeup of
lawyers seriously how many are left-wing
their disdain slash hatred of president
trump combined with the fear of others
left him with very few options my only
question is does it have to be lawyers
clearly this isn't a judicial proceeding
with no real judge presiding and it's
all for show
so why not have you go up there and
defend president trump well i don't
think i'm the guy to do it but your
question about
you know because the lawyers for trump
are doing a terrible job i think we all
agree on that
uh particularly the one lawyer at least
bruce castor
does he have to have to be a lawyer at
all could it just be anybody that gets
up that he hires
i i would assume yeah it could be
anybody um but
but even so the problem again is that
trump's one of his great weaknesses like
i said yesterday one of his great
weaknesses
uh is is in personnel in his hiring
decisions
we saw this going all the way back to
the campaign through
the administration and even now so
whether he's hiring lawyers or not
he does not appear to be the best judge
of talent
so i think that would be the case no
matter who he was hiring
and one of the reasons for that is that
for trump
the number one thing he's looking for is
undying unyielding
loyalty to him which
yes of course you you want people you
hire to be loyal to you
but that shouldn't be the only thing
you're looking for
but for trump it appears that's really
it he just wants someone who's loyal to
him and says nice things about him
um but there are a lot of people who are
who are talented and could do a great
job
yet they have minds of their own so they
may not line up with you 100
on everything yet for trump that's
disqualifying
and so he rules out a lot of what would
otherwise be talented people
um this is from laura
books refer brooks referring to the
story we led the show with yesterday
officer siknik
was reported to have been killed by a
blow to the head
during the riot but no evidence has been
given that such a blow was ever
delivered no evidence has been found
that he was killed by any action taken
by any person in the crowd in dc
at least if there is evidence of that
they're not telling us laura says as an
emt i can guarantee that if somebody has
trauma to cause death it would be
obvious without an autopsy
yeah that's that's that's again what i
would assume that if someone the
original story we were told
about sicnik is that he was beat to
death by
by someone in the crowd or multiple
people in the crowd
and you would think even though i'm not
a doctor i would assume
that if somebody was bludgeoned to death
um
you'd be able to tell it would be pretty
obvious during the medical examination
and the autopsy if not before that as
you point out
but even if it's not now you you could
argue that sometimes someone could
in a sort of a freak occurrence someone
could suffer a blow to the head
and it's not immediately obvious and
then die later because of the the
internal damage that was done i suppose
that sort of thing has happened
but even there then you'd be able to
tell in the autopsy except they're not
releasing the autopsy
and i i cannot imagine
any good reason i can imagine a number
of reasons why they wouldn't release the
autopsy
i can't think of any good reason it's
hard for me to imagine an ethical reason
when there's so much interest public
interest in this case
uh when it's being referred to so often
in the
in the impeachment trial proceedings
when it's
this is one of the things being used as
a reason to
have the military occupying dc
uh because of all those reasons the
public has a real interest
in what actually killed officer siknik
yet they're not telling us the autopsy
results
jack walsh finally says matt please help
my marriage is in shambles i've tried to
get help through counseling with no
results to speak of
i thought the problem would work itself
out with time or i could learn to live
with it but since my son is almost two
now
i now see that it is unlikely to work no
matter how much i plead what factual and
logical arguments can i put forward or
emotional connections i try to make
my wife still puts ketchup on meatloaf
i'm at my wit's end
and i'm desperate i've been there before
uh jack i understand what you're going
through all i can say is just take over
the meatloaf making duties that's what i
did at my house
that's the only that's what you need to
do to save your marriage
godspeed god bless yeah this has been
obviously a really difficult year for
businesses
um to put it very mildly but i've been
impressed to see
small business owners and others
pivoting
and adjusting to this reality
and finding ways to to stay alive and in
many cases actually thrive
businesses have had to be pretty
flexible this past year from working
remotely to pivoting their business
models for long-term survival and growth
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business these pivots have made your job
even more challenging especially if
you've had to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place that you
can always count on to make hiring
faster and easier that's
ziprecruiter.com
walsh ziprecruiter.com walsh when you
post a job on zip recruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 top job boards with one
click so it's very easy for you then zip
recruiter
uh they use their powerful technology to
find people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and they actively invite those people to
apply so this is not just like putting
something out there into the ether and
hoping that
someone the right person finds it
they're actively pursuing pursuing
candidates for you it's no wonder that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you can see for
yourself right now you can try zip
recruiter for free
at
ziprecruiter.comwalls.ziprecruiter.comwalsh
let ziprecruiter take hiring off your
plates you can focus on growing your
business
go to ziprecruiter.com walsh
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
and here's another smart thing um and
also possibly the best news you're gonna
hear
all day maybe all year right now using
promo code walsh you'll get
10 off any daily wire membership plan
let me tell you if you're not a member
you're missing all the best stuff
you're being left out in the cold and
you don't want that anymore
so use this promo code get 10 off what
makes a membership so great well members
get our articles ad-free they get access
to all of our live broadcasts they get
the show library they get two hours
two full hours the ben shapiro show they
get our always growing catalog
of content and we've got so much more
got a lot of we got a lot of extra
content now much more to come down the
road plus
with our all access you'll get um two of
the greatest
of all beverage vessels the leftist
tiers tumbler
all of that plus 10 off when you use
promo code walsh so go over to
dailywire.com
and become a member today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel male
breastfeeders well we can't can't really
cancel
them because they don't exist never have
existed cannot exist
so instead we're canceling the people
who want us to pretend
they exist reading now from the daily
wire says in great britain a group of
hospitals
has instructed midwives and their
maternity departments to use different
terms when treating transgender patients
in order to be more gender inclusive
substituting
chest feeding for breastfeeding
replacing breast milk with human milk
or breast slash chest milk
gross or milk from the feeding mother or
parent
terms like chest feeding and human milk
are being introduced at nhs
trusts in a bid to boost inclusivity
bristol live reports staff has been
instructed
uh to use gender-neutral language
alongside not instead of traditional
terms
that ensure that all groups are
represented um
lbc reported of brighton and sussex
university hospital nhs trust
the hospitals will become the first in
the uk to introduce an official
gender inclusive language policy for its
maternity services departments
which will be rebranded as perinatal
services
terms such as woman and father will also
be superseded by
woman or person and parent co-parent
or second biological parent respectively
brighton and sussex university
hospital's nhs trust explains in his
announcements of the changes
we are on a journey towards gender
inclusive care for everybody during
pregnancy birth and afterwards
this journey is led by members of the
trans and non-binary community
we're at the beginning of this process
which will continue over the next few
years
midwives believe pregnancy and birth are
normal healthy parts of life
the midwife's role is to support a
pregnant person's journey through each
stage of pregnancy birth in the early
days with their new baby
midwives believe that you know what is
best for you and your baby
and we'll work together with you to
ensure your experience of pregnancy and
birth is safe and possible
possible positive that is okay now we
can all agree hopefully that
human milk and chest milk are the most
disturbing and revolting rebranding
attempts
in world history even worse than new
coke probably as for the chest
feeding concept now i have all the
criticisms you'd expect me to have and
that any sane person would have namely
that
there is no such thing as being gender
inclusive when it comes to childbirth
and lactation
these are things that only women can do
or will ever be able to do and frankly
as a man
i'm quite grateful for that i i am more
than happy to leave all of the birthing
and the lactating
to my wife i have to admit that on the
three occasions that my wife has been
pregnant
um i thought to myself nearly every day
man i am so glad that i'm not the one
who has to do this
but whether i'm happy with it or not the
reality is still the reality
there is no room for inclusion here it's
just like um
only fish have gills okay you can wish
that you have gills and you can insist
that you have gills and you can tell
everybody to call you
carl the carp or whatever but if you
jump into a lake and sit at the bottom
without an oxygen max
mask for several minutes you're gonna
drown it doesn't matter what you think
or how you feel
the reality is the reality a man can say
that he's a woman and identify as one
but he will never give birth and never
lactate ever period
just like a woman can say she's a man
but the fact that she can give birth
and can lactate means that she is not a
man and will never be one period
these are all the obvious points to make
but
let me mention two others the first is
this
although not everyone can breastfeed
everyone does have breasts breast is an
already inclusive term
we all have them they typically look
different between
women and men though not in all cases
but all members of the human species
have breasts
that's why men can even get breast
cancer it's rare but it does happen
because men have breasts so even if you
were trying to include men in
breastfeeding
there's no reason to change the word
breast men have those
it's the feeding part that complicates
matters
in a similar fashion all women have
chests
all people have chests and breasts
because those are interchangeable terms
which is why changing the term
is superfluous and pointless all you've
succeeded in doing is making it sound
weird
i mean it wouldn't be technically wrong
to say that you went to popeyes and
ordered a bucket of chicken chests
but it sounds weird and there's no
reason to say it a chest is a breast is
a chest as a breast okay
once again proponents of left-wing
gender theory reveal themselves to have
absolutely no understanding of human
anatomy
they apparently think that that women
don't have chests i mean
i wonder if they think we need different
names for male and female arms and legs
too
see this is the irony the left says that
it doesn't like gendered language but
what they end up doing is making
non-gendered language gendered and then
changing it on the basis that it's
gendered
if you recall a very similar thing
happened with the amen a women debacle a
few weeks ago
they take a word that is not gendered
they make it gendered and then they
change it because it is gendered
even though they're the ones who made it
gendered one other point
um this is more than just
silly and stupid it's both of those
things of course but it's more
and this is dangerous imagine what will
happen if these lunatics get their way
and succeed in convincing some people at
least
that babies can be fed by men through
chest feeding
babies will die in that case because
again no matter what the left's ideology
says no matter what they might want the
simple reality is that babies need milk
from women
or else a direct substitute of milk from
women in the form of formula
if they latch on to a man and start
suckling they're gonna come up empty
we're in a world now where not everybody
understands that basic point
and i'm not joking when i say that we
will eventually start hearing stories
about malnourished and starving infants
who are being breastfed by their fathers
who identify as mothers
don't think it's too crazy nothing is
ever too crazy anymore
if modern culture has taught us anything
it's that
nothing is ever too crazy and so the
people pushing chest feeding
are of course very much canceled
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling our
technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
house democrats undermine the case for
impeachment
the 1619 project new york times
journalist
doxes a conservative journalist and
france tells america to stop
exporting wokeness check it out on the
michael knowles show